hi this is Bob Ali from Homer films I'm
here on the D show and in a few minutes
I'll be talking about my story to Islam
this little ad hundred and uh assalamu
alaykum welcome to another episode of
the Deen show thank you for tuning in we
got some great news when we come back
he's gonna be telling us his story how
he went from living according to his
desires which led him to doing some
funny and unique things crazy things to
the submission and to surrender to the
one God
we'll be back with our next guest baba
ali here on a Dean show you don't want
to go nowhere
there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger maybe maybe it's just to break
the ice a Salam alaykoum while comes
something to LA how are you brother
hamdullah how are you doing hum do the
law all praises to the crater who's
given us his ability and United us to be
together again I'm here on the Deen show
had ought to be here
Bravo Li it's gonna be some fun today
inshallah so I was introducing the
trying to deduce the topic but it's very
unique because you came to Islam and you
mentioned something about witchcraft I
didn't know how to I've had guests come
over from Christianity from this isn't
that isn't but is this actually it was
this a religion you can say it was
somewhat of a religion because it's
actually called a religion of Wicca and
when you don't have guidance you really
have no guidance and I resort down to
trying to find something to clinch on to
and I started putting rocks around my
neck and believing that these rocks and
these pebbles had just like the people
used to worship idols that these things
can actually give me something and let's
talk about your past now let's get right
into the topic this is very interesting
for me and for a lot of our viewers
because I'm we never covered something
like this and I'm sure there was is this
a big row bizarre couldn't be a call to
cult of religion is a big father there's
a lot of people practicing this and it
is it's strange it's a strange world you
have our people who write books in blood
and indeed they have spells and you have
people who were albums and think that
these things were actually bring them
good things and unfortunately you see
some of this to cross over to people who
are quote unquote religious yeah follow
superstition all this stuff is all
nonsense by the way yeah and when I came
to a some I didn't I didn't I find was
enlightened and saw the truth but
realized that these things mean have
nothing they can do nothing for you well
let's back it up tell us how did you now
were you're obviously you know usually
as we're taught that everyone is born in
a pure State yes in a pure state that if
you left that
child to grow up alone that he would
grow up not worshipping the Sun the moon
or you know which is or what not but
usually this is nurtured and he gets
kind of influenced by the surroundings
that are around him
what were your surroundings while you
were growing up were there witches
around you who were no no I just called
her
what were you were you born into a
family that was predominantly what my
family was predominately secular uh-huh
so they really didn't practice any type
of religion whatsoever yeah and this is
why they say basically can do whatever
you want to do as long as you get good
grades yeah so like just a typical yeah
yeah you know I don't worship rocks
go-ahead worship rocks as long as you
get your A's that's all we care about
yeah and unfortunately they don't
realize that these things are even more
important than my education education is
very important but at the same time the
way your behavior your attitude you're
not just dislike more importantly
Hereafter yeah no one thinks about the
hereafter you always think about this
dunya they think my successes in this
dunya but the real success isn't
Hereafter that doesn't mean you ignore
the success in this life but
unfortunately many parents who are
secular they don't think about giving
you the guidance for the next life yeah
so now you were growing up and now
you're a teen at around what age did you
get into this freaky stuff I think was
about the age of like 18 uh-huh about 18
years old and like just looking for
something or just bored looking for
something because I had no religion
nothing yeah I just knew there was there
was a God but I don't know what to
answer what the truth was just like many
people who are looking for the truth out
there that's how usually is right yeah
yeah so and there's a first thing I
couldn't have found so I clinched on to
it and tell us go on this is so I start
taking these rocks and putting them
around my neck think these rocks are
gonna benefit me and eventually came to
a point that I realized that these rocks
are the creation and either you have a
choice of Wersching meaning either the
creation or the Creator and I said these
rocks can't even save themselves how
they're gonna help me and I put those
rocks down and said I need to start
looking for the truth so and that's why
I started my quest of looking for the
truth tell us some other ways of life
that you came upon that you were and
what were the things that you were
looking for so that person who's also
sincere and he's
I need to know the truth he can kind of
take a shortcut I'm studying taking it
long way around to learn from some of
your mistakes well first of all I said
to myself okay if the creator is
unlimited and he's all-powerful and he's
perfect then his religion must be
perfect so let me start looking at all
these different people who say oh our
religion is the truth because everyone
you speak to there's all this religions
of truth and this we're sent by God and
bla bla bla so I said okay I'll give
everyone the benefit of the doubt
let me try everything out let me see
what was out there every time I came
into a study of religion every time I
found a mistake or I found an error or I
found it's been changed by man I put it
to the side mm-hmm I mean how can that
be a religion from God if has mistakes
in it yeah also I realized that okay if
if God like for example they say Oh God
couldn't die or God is a statue and yeah
if I can break your God then that can't
be God yeah so I say okay every time if
I want steak and put it to the side
eventually I came across the last
religion which was left with which was
Islam it's interesting how I got to that
point because at the time where it came
for me to look into Islam my father got
onto his a heart attack
and he was in the hospital and the
doctor said he's gonna triple bypass
surgery and that surgery was
unsuccessful so they told he's gonna die
so I'm singing at you silly a hospital
and singing am I basically my father's
deathbed and I was supposed to go to a
winter camp to learn about Islam and my
mother said don't go stay here because
this is more important because your
father can pass away you can go to your
little quest in the future yeah and I
told my parents okay I'll stay and as I
sat there next to my father watching him
on his quote-unquote deathbed I realized
that this can be me because when you go
to a graveyard they don't die when
they're old they die in all types of
ages they have infants they have
toddlers they have teenagers they're
people my age they have people who are
old it's always everything no one knows
when death is gonna come so I told
myself I can be dead if if Islam is a
truth let me go least investigate it
because I can die before hey this guy
passes away yeah
so I tell my mom I'm changing my mind
and I'm gonna go she was completely
against it and I went and when I went
there I was just has zero idea what
Islam is about zero took my girlfriend
to Islamic camp with me
but before that you had investigated all
the different ways of light Buddhism and
this looked at way your life in that way
of life yeah whatever whatever was out
there yes and it just for the face of it
didn't fit I came from a science major
yeah when you look at the Bible says the
earth has four corners yeah basically
this is the whole argument between the
earth is flat and the earth is round the
the it that's wrong it's isn't that flat
I mean the scientists are fighting it
and the church was throwing these people
into prison it's and now they've
realized oh yeah maybe it's not flat
well the Muslims we knew this 1,400
years ago that it's not flat and when I
found the scientific miracles of the
Quran that was amazing to me I mean if
you any science person they always
always science versus Christianity and
it is always a debate trying to discover
each other always debating it even when
I was in high school
to debating Christianity or what they
call creation creationism versus science
but Islam and science they don't
conflict I mean some people yes you come
up with theories but that's not fat but
fact it doesn't conflict with Islam yeah
and that to me was amazing and the
miracles within the the scientific
miracles was amazing to me so that's one
of the first things that I caught my
attention when I start looking into
Islam in that winter camp now before we
go on and we talked about how finally
you were overtaken or you found that
this was indeed the truth let's talk
about quickly some of these other ways
because now if somebody came to you and
was talking to you about God being a man
for instance yes like some people today
to take you know one of the greatest
messengers of God is a man yes did you
ever come in and have a dialogue with
someone about this yes to talk to them
and say why this didn't make sense to
you yes there's actually a person
knocked on my door and they're you know
knocking my door trying preach the
message and at that time I was still
searching and I hadn't really said the
Quran too much but I just trying to get
into it and the guy knocked my door and
said I'm here to spread the good message
and Jesus is coming
blah blah blah so I said okay and he
opens up his book as GME proof for this
because I'm actually looking for the
truth and he says yes let me read you
this passage and I said before you read
it to me
who wrote this passage he says well this
is written by so-and-so as a way ii are
you hundred percent sure he says well I
think so I mean he looked open in the
back of it and it shows some of them
they know some of them they don't know
some of them are question marks and I
say is this original language that this
book was revealed it says no it was then
it was translated to Latin then
translate to English and me having
English is my second language I know
that when you translate something from
another language to another language it
loses meaning and so first of all the
book is not you're not her percent sure
who wrote it - it's been translated and
it has a book been changed so yes it's
been changed as well you're asking very
good questions yes and then I start
thinking you know what these are very
good things are you typing these guys
knocking at my door says but what do you
think I said you know what I don't know
I'm still looking for the truth - so
what have you come across when your
truth seeking I said the last book I'm
trying to get into is the Quran so Kay
what is that about
so which are having this dialogue with
each other and I tell him that so far
the Quran there I've been looking at so
far it's just before I even look at the
text there's only one version of it even
though there's different people have
different ideas there's only one version
of the Quran in Arabic and that's it and
the book has not been changed and the
book has the same style all the way from
beginning to end and so while this is
very unique so yeah so by the time a guy
loved it I'm gonna go look at the to the
Quran it's knocking on your door to
preach to you and try to have you come
over but you look into the Quran that
was it yeah that lock ended up okay I
gave up a look into it too and we just
ended up it was a very nice it comes in
so this is amazing how about the idea
that now somebody and I heard you talk
about this before I forgot exactly how
you explained it but the idea that
someone is coming to die for your sins
yes you made an analogy about this can
you talk about this yeah you know if you
take a situation like let's say I have
one of my co-workers I work with he says
you know X Y Z came and Jesus came and
died for your sins
you have basically green light I mean
everything's okay and I said if we
thought the same way if we thought in
this and the world thought this way that
someone has taken care of everything
it's like giving you a credit card says
you know what no matter what you charge
your bill will be paid for imagine what
type of chaos you would have in this
society if people didn't know that
they're gonna be accountable for their
deeds there's someone else will be
taking care of everything for you you'll
become blinking off you know what I kill
somebody but it's okay Jesus will
forgive me now you know what so I did
that but Jesus will forgive me you know
what had this temptation to cheat on
somebody or cheat him in business or
cheat on a woman or cheat on this but
you know what Jesus will take care of it
because he died for me because I'm
sinful and he will take care of it if
people had this mentality imagine how
much chaos there would be but if Psalm
teaches the exact opposite it says no
one's gonna take care of it you will be
held accountable
everyone will be held accountable if you
do good you get good if you do bad you
get back this is what we in this society
teach you don't go to the court and say
you know what I kill people but guess
what I know the judge would take care of
it
imagine how that would be so to us it's
like when you go to courses what did you
do did you do this yes did you you can
be accountable for it if you did good
you get good if you did bad you can get
punished for it and that's what it's on
teaches us now that just makes sense it
goes down easy goes down well easy to
digest tell us now you're at this camp
you said yes
okay tell us what happened now so I go
to the camp and it's interesting because
what happens is my girlfriend's on one
side I'm on the other side and men and
women are separated we never seen when
many women separated before and I've
never seen this before
yeah this is all new to me and and we
see I sit at a table for lunch and
dinner and my table surrounded with all
these people with different colour faces
because you can go to high school you go
to college you see everyone the Hispanic
people hang out together
black people hang out together white
people hang out together the the guys
with the punk music they hang out
together you guys will be basketball
they hang out together by default just
like animals we segregate based on our
color or find some
simple bond to connect with well I know
what we're all from a Persia or we're
all from here and when I went to the
camp
I really wow these people are all
different and they're all hanging out
with each other so I asked them you guys
must know each other for like 10 years
now right say no we just met yesterday
uh-huh I was like well there's something
unique about these people I want to know
more what bothers you guys together and
he tells me uh it's long and I quickly
learned that we don't have a choice of a
color skin we're born in your skin is
white I'm darker and more barbecued and
there's people who are black people
green yellow we no one asked us what
color skin you're gonna be Mourning look
what were you were you where do you want
to be born in what language you want to
speak so that's a very very weak bond
for us to connect ourselves with but we
do have a choice of the ideas we want to
carry and we're bond two people together
with the ideas that they carry that
makes a strong bond and that is what I
saw and seeing Islam implemented by
action and not just by a bunch of words
or a pamphlet that's what amazed me and
made me want to learn more about it now
you asked a very important question when
that person individual came to your door
you said what's the proof what was the
proof for Islam that also had you along
with this convinced there was a couple
of things there's one that the
linguistic things yeah within it I was
amazed on the simplicity of it what
Islam taught be good to your parents you
know some of the religious yes they do
teach some similar things don't be bad
do good blah blah blah but some of the
things were just it was just amazing how
things just click the made sense you
know the until recently we we had a
black president and this was a very big
deal in America Wow we choose a person
with dark skin they don't talk about
intelligence which is far more
intelligent than the last president they
don't choose talk about this in just a
very fact that his skin pigment of his
skin is a little bit darker than our
skin this should be a very big deal that
look how far we've come
you go back to Islam and what Islam
taught it got rid of racism by the time
of the second relief which was equipment
like the second president here yeah and
by that time the person who was a slave
in Egypt
was a governor in Egypt and this was a
black man it wasn't a big deal didn't
make the newspaper is they make there
all this in the history books
Islam came to teach us in to enlighten
us to go away from these animal
instincts of animal desires and animal
mentality to come us to enlighten us to
raise raise us to make us better than
everything else to not follow our
desires but to follow our Creator and
shablow and that's what amazed me okay
so what happens now now you're amazed
you're convinced I mean did you have to
go get dipped in a pool what happened
that's a big big ceremony oh and did you
have to jump no ropes I told myself if I
ever find the truth I'll follow it and
this means if you have to sacrifice
things that you desire yeah and I liked
my girlfriend very much but this thing
was much more than just a girlfriend I
mean this thing was more important than
this is if I found the truth and so if I
were convinced that this is the truth I
will follow it and I was convinced and I
said I'm going I told my girlfriend I
look I can't be girlfriend boyfriend
anymore because I wanna do things
Islamic Lee and it's not me please look
you take responsibility it's like okay
no I just go around this girl with this
girl with this girl you want a girl you
can have a girl but you have to accept
the responsibility of taking care of her
providing for her feeding her you know
and if she has a child you take care of
that you take every responsibility again
accountability is here no more you know
what who cares do just think about me me
me now I have to think of my Creator and
make sure I please him and by pleasing
him I have to take care of my wife my
children etc so I told you I can't have
a girlfriend boyfriend relationship
anymore and that it wasn't easy for her
so I told you this is over the
relationship is over unless we get
married the relationship is over
from there I my friends so my friends I
came with they came to just check out
what I'm learning about and Tom look I
used to be Persian but I'm a Persian
anymore I'm Muslim know which what that
means basically is that not that okay I
can take away from where I'm born in but
that culture part of the culture that is
a practice that will conflict with the
some I'm not gonna practice anymore the
mentality that men are better than women
you know and we have this pride of my
country is better than because our
Persian ancestors all the stuff is out
the window now you know
now people are people this is like it's
like a clean slate it cleared up my mind
it's like you put these glasses on that
you can actually see now that I've been
blinded for all this time and that's it
just enlighten my thinking so what did
you have to do to become a Muslim to
become Muslim is very simple all you do
is give your Shahada a sedan la ilaha
illallah wash anna muhammadan rasul
allah which means i bear witness that
there is no god but Allah and Muhammad
peace and blessings upon him is the
final and last messenger that's it the
same God that was from Abraham Jesus
Moses and the final prophet is Muhammad
and we accept all the prophets before
him and the messages before them but our
book for us as Muslims and for not just
Muslims for the whole world is the Quran
and to follow it it will give you
success in the hereafter and inshallah
that is more important than anything
that we can gain here in this don't you
tell us before we come to an end and a
close that for you living the typical
life as a youth getting involved in a
lot of the things that are out there you
know you know you stopped you started to
really ponder and think about more
important things you started to actually
search for the truth many people they
don't want to do that they're not
thinking about death they're not
thinking about the hereafter what advice
would you give someone because you're
very young and at the age you were
younger when you accepted the truth for
somebody who is at that age that you
were to give them some encouragement and
advice to really think and stop and know
it's not all about the nightclub it's
not all about chasing and get the rims
on the car is not all about chasing the
women and the good times what advice do
you give to somebody like this to stop
and think you know the thing that we're
there's sort of so much stuff that we're
not sure about in this life I can go
study all as much as I want and I may
not even get my degree attend I maybe my
life might be taken before that I'm sure
many of us know people who didn't know
the death was coming for them you have
situations where you struggle for so
much that you think is so important is
so so important for you and you get it
and like that's it now something else
becomes so so important and then you get
that anything that's it everything in
this life is so ten
hurry and something is so important
today becomes nothing tomorrow but
paradise is forever and I said to myself
I'm not sure about a lot of things
that's going on in this world but one
thing I am sure about and no matter what
religion you are no matter what even or
atheist whatever one thing is guaranteed
guaranteed is every soul shall taste
death everyone's gonna die do you know
what's gonna happen when you're gonna
die
are you a hundred percent sure you know
what's gonna happen when you die because
unless you are 100% sure you better
start investigating I'm not saying just
look into it it's not a look Essam toss
to think not to blindly follow look at
all these religions compare them see
look at the systems of life and you'll
be amazed I mean it's very clear it's
not very complicated all is very clear
and hopefully made allah subhan to
enlighten you and make you towards the
right path expect now there's some
tunnels because you did say and it's the
third one we caught some Arabic words
you're gonna have to define them they
heard Islam they heard Muslim and you
just said Allah you have to find these
bodies the word Allah means one God so
Arabic way of Arabic word for one God
it's very clear
the word Islam is submission to one God
ISM and this is the religion that
Muslims practice which is Muslims are
the ones who submit to God that's it
that's it it's not as simple is they
replicated people think you know this
whole if you gotta be someone who is
religious or you follow this God
conscious lifestyle that you have to be
some weird person if you have to be
someone locked up most people I mean you
hang out with me I go play basketball I
go do this I go dad you have a normal
life but I I do everything within the
boundaries of Islam and that means like
if I'm gonna go have fun I do it I don't
have to with our alcohol without drugs
without this if I want sometimes I do
stuff this against my own desires I want
to go do something and my parents will
tell me I don't want you to go now
before some who cares I'll go do it but
after a song I realized I'm responsible
of listening to my parents and they
raised me they took care of me
our loss upon teller wants us to listen
to our parents as long as it doesn't
conflict with the song I have to listen
to it so sometimes you have to follow
something you don't even desire but you
do it with the hope that you would gain
reward for it in the hereafter in Shaba
what are some of the misconceptions that
nowadays you travel a lot you're all
over the place that you've seen that
people have about Islam I think a lot of
people unfortunately because of you know
in the media like Fox News and all the
stuff you see on television they have
this they put people on TV that are so
unfortunate a very very small fraction
of what's out there and they they get
this people that may not mean a little
very little about Islam and they're the
ones were the voice they're the loudest
speakers and they give the voice and
they give the misconception what Islam
is really about the best way to find out
what Islam is really about is to find a
practicing Muslim and go ask them and
that will clear everything up don't
listen to the media don't sin to the
movies that's all the stuff is for
entertainment and to get people into
fear and all that kind of stuff real is
to see and just like you do in real life
if I want to go see what a vegetarian
does I'll go hang out and ask a
vegetarian why you guys eat veggies so
you go see most of say how come you guys
do this and how can we do that and ask
the person who practices it because a
practicing was not just some guy who his
name is you know Ali this is because
there was Ali doesn't mean he is many of
us are born into the religion but not
necessarily convinced of it yeah
now tell us we got a couple minutes left
some of this wonderful work you're doing
you travel a lot you're all over the
place tell of some of your projects as
you got going on well I have a few
different projects I do I do when videos
called Omer films um mah fi lm s calm
and that's where I put up videos trying
to clear up some of the misconceptions
of what we Muslims born people who are
born to Islam are doing this incorrect
and I hum do love when i mean i'm d'lai
all praises due to Allah that Allah
showed me Islam before he showed me the
Muslims and the reason for that is
because sometimes you see Muslims doing
stuff to have nothing to do with the
song which is really one of the main
reasons that people have a lot of
misconceptions of Islam's
yeah absolutely yeah so I that's why
it's better to study the text and see
what islam teaches rather than hey
muslim i see this guy doing something
strange i wonder if that's what islam
teaches like forced marriages some
muslims practices full force marriages
things and that's nothing to do with
some it's actually a psalm forbids it
and if you look at the Islamic texts a
woman can doesn't get married her
marriage is not valid unless she
approves of the person she was married
getting married - yeah so and that's one
project and I have boardgames
Baba looey Gamescom and I'm inventing
boardgames that both Muslims and
non-muslims complained I have a project
called half our Deen which the logo I'm
wearing and I try to help people find
each other for marriage - Jacque Aloha
thank you very much for being with us
here on the Deen show desuka
thank you very much for inviting me had
a great time thank you and thank you for
tuning in to another episode of the Deen
show I hope you got to benefit we're
here every week trying to help you
understand Islam and Muslims and we look
forward
God willing to have you back again for
another episode of the Deen show next
week until then
assalamu alaikum peace be unto you
well of whom will our collimator to a
hyena
how horrid I mean ha ha ha
well Hajin I mean her husband's I mean
who you know what y'all Neffe ha ha
meaning what I love you I don't wanna
feel I mean I love you
leopoldo me somebody
one more minute ye d Avinash whoa
so behind let the upon us what you call
me madam be to love me to love go I mean
um
whose Emami
well honestly homie
I will fire you though
Mobley
question so Tajiri any Mostafavi la la
de kaddipudi rulers easy lady quano
palma ropa de una Humana's illa hot doc
a neuron in the body the Sham Samba
Villa ha
- Derek alpha male loser
awkward
beefing up genius behold